[Musique]
margaret trudeau s'est retrouvé sous les
projecteurs dans les années 70 d'abord
en doivent dans les pousses du premier
ministre pierre elliott trudeau puis à
cause de son amour pour la fête avec les
milliards jack nicholson est la nôtre
owen de ce monde
avec maintenant dispo petits enfants
margaret trudeau a décidé de révéler
quelques uns de ses secrets dans un
spectacle diagnostic est maniaco
dépressive
la mère du premier ministre justin
trudeau aborde le sujet sans détour dans
son spectacle
c'est le décès de son fils michel en
1998 qu'il l'a poussé à aller chercher
encore plus dès dimanche
margaret trudeau à trouver le juste
équilibre et elle se réjouit que son
fils fasse de même
aujourd'hui celle qui est la seule
canadienne à avoir été à la fois lipouz
puis la mère de premier ministre du
canada n'a aucun regret je ne regrette
rien
après avoir monté sur la scène de just
for laugh margaret trudeau présentera
son spectacle à new york en septembre
prochain
ici louis philippe ouimet radio canada
montréal